-Finally,
it is Wednesday night,
and you know what that means.
It's "Tonight Show"
Audience Trivia Night!
-♪ "Tonight Show"
Audience Trivia Night ♪
♪♪
-Now, I'm going to ask
random people
in the audience
a trivia question,
and if you answer correctly,
you win a prize.
Who wants to play?
Anyone want to play?
No one on this side
wants to play?
Over here. Come here.
Oh, yeah. Hi, here you go.
Ready for --
What is your name?
-Ella.
-Ella, where are you from?
-California.
-Hey. Welcome, Ella!
[ Applause ]
Alright, here's the question.
-Seconds.
Milliseconds.
-Judges?
[ Buzzer ]
Ooh, I'm sorry, the answer was,
"Trump's encounter
with Stormy Daniels."
Sorry. Thank you so much.
Thank you for playing.
Who else wants to play?
You right there, buddy?
Hey, here you go. Here you go.
What's your name
and where are you from?
-Michael From Texas.
-Michael from Texas!
-C'mon, Texas!
-Texas, alright.
Here's the question.
-I don't know.
The one down?
[ Laughter ]
-The one down. Judges?
[ Buzzer ]
I'm sorry, it was Ozempic.
Ozempic. Thank you so much.
How about, who else?
Anyone over here?
Yes. Hey, bud.
How you doing? That's for you.
That's a great shirt.
-Thank you.
-What is your name?
Where are you from?
-Cory from Detroit, Michigan.
-Yeah, Detroit!
[ Applause ]
Alright, here we go.
-Frostbite?
-Judges?
[ Buzzer ]
No, skiing with Gwyneth Paltrow.
Thank you so much.
Thank you. I appreciate that.
Let's go around here.
I'll go around.
I'll go around this side.
There you go.
Hey, how are you guys doing?
Doing good. Looking good.
Good-looking audience.
Hey, bud! Get up. Get up!
What's your name?
-Loic.
-Louie?
-Loic. French.
French name.
-Loic?
-Yeah.
-Wow.
Loic from France.
Thank you so much
for being here.
Here you go. You hold that.
I'll give you the question here.
Ready, Loic?
-The government. Yeah?
-Government?
[ Buzzer ]
TikTok. Thank you so much.
I appreciate it.
Thank you for being here.
We have time for one more.
Right there. Come on.
Nice to see you.
-Hi.
-What is your name
and where are you from?
-Victoria Ybarra from
California.
-Yeah, Victoria from California!
Alright, the question is...
-A bar keeper?
[ Buzzer ]
-We were looking
for "Spirit Airlines pilot."
Sorry. Thank you
so much for being here.
Unfortunately, no one took home
the prize tonight.
We'll try again next week
on "Tonight Show"
Audience Trivia Night.
Stick around!
We'll be right back
with Matt Damon, everybody!
Come on back!